[Applaudissements]
avec mes amis
il ya un jeu auquel on adore jouer c'est
le jeu qui s'appelle tu préfères vous
savez c'est ce jeu dont les règles
ma foi sont assez simple consiste à
poser une question qui commence comme
son nom l'indiqué part je préfère dans
le but de faire rentrer son adversaire
dans un dilemme ou tout du moins lui
faire prendre une décision qu'il n'aura
jamais à prendre de toute sa vie et un
jour un ami m'a posé la question
suivante est ce que tu préfères vivre
jusqu'à 40 ans avec la vie de justin
bieber ou bien vivre jusqu'à l'espérance
de vie normale en france mais conservait
sa vie actuelle
alors j'ai pas tout de suite compris le
dilemme dans cette question pourquoi est
ce que je vendrai trente ans de ma vie
voire peut-être 40 pour avoir la vie de
justin bieber comme si la vie de justin
bieber va les 30 ou 40 ans de la mienne
alors pour mieux comprendre
je lui ai posé la question je vais
demander pourquoi est-ce que tu as
choisi justin bieber je pense vraiment
que sa vie est meilleure que la mienne
alors ne me jugez pas parce que c'est
pas moi qui parle à ce moment là bah oui
que je crois il est beau riche
talentueux et beaucoup de gens l'aiment
ah bon ça veut donc dire que sa vie est
meilleure que la mienne
oui gros respecte et là le grand réveil
il avait l'air tellement sûr de lui qui
pouvait pas avoir tort c'est donc ça la
rue
la question comment réussir sa vie c'est
être riche beau talentueux et faire en
sorte que beaucoup de gens nous aiment
merci beaucoup
très bonne soirée évidemment qu'ils
avaient tort évidemment
alors plutôt que de rentrer dans un
débat stérile avec cet ami j'ai préféré
trouver un contre exemple pourquoi
est-ce que tu m'a demandé si je voulais
prendre la vidéo justin bieber est pas
je sais pas moi
kurt cobain ou dalida par exemple alors
je suis vraiment désolé d'utiliser des
exemples aussi sinistre mais dalida elle
était riche
elle était belle talentueuse et beaucoup
de gens l'aimaient et beaucoup de gens
l'aiment encore et pourtant elle aurait
même écrit ma vie est insupportable
pardonnez moi avant de mettre fin à ses
jours
c'est quand même malheureux pour une
personne qui chantait voulant mourir sur
scène
alors cette glauque analogie nous nous
mène à un questionnement kurt cobain
dalida on peut tout à fait penser qu'ils
ont plutôt bien réussi dans la vie
mais peut-on pour autant considérer que
leur vie a été une réussite
alors entre parenthèses si je suis ici
aujourd'hui c'est certainement pas parce
que je suis riche beau talentueux et
aimé par beaucoup de monde comme dalida
ou kurt cobain mais c'est encore moins
pour vous présenter une de mes créations
ou de mes découvertes
à vrai dire je crois que je serais même
difficilement capable de produire quoi
que ce soit qui est un rapport avec ce
pour quoi j'ai été formé et même plus
fort que ça je crois que j'ai plus
appris au cours de ma formation à me
vendre qu'à faire ce que je prétendais
savoir faire quand il s'agissait de
mende
non je rigole
en réalité j'en ai appris des choses
pendant ma formation en fait j'ai quand
même été un profil assez prisé dans les
entreprises mais ça c'est parce que à
chaque fois que je me retrouvais en
entretien qu'on me demander mais
pourquoi est ce que vous avez décidé
d'être ingénieur alors en génie civil
accessoirement jeu
pour des quelque chose comme parce que
je rêve de participer à la construction
de ce monde et non pas sa destruction
c'était le plus bel argument à peu près
honnête que j'ai trouvé pour justifier
mes choix et c'était sincère
j'avais réellement envie de participer à
la construction de ce monde
quoi qu'il en soit je sais que cette
volonté réside pas seulement en moi je
sais que beaucoup de gens se retrouvent
dans cette volonté leur est même encore
plus fort que ça je suis certain que
cette volonté réside au moins
inconsciemment en chacun d'entre nous
enfin malgré tout ça grâce à cette
phrase percutante
c'est punchline comme on dit j'ai eu
l'occasion de vivre plusieurs
expériences professionnelles des
expériences avec des salaires attrayants
dans des bureaux prestigieux et
promettant des perspectives d'évolution
comme on rêve dans l'amour tout au long
de nos études mais jusqu alors
toutes ces expériences professionnelles
non seulement montré ce qu'était réussir
dans la vie au sens commun du terme pas
ce qu'était réussir sa vie
est ce que vous comprenez l'analogie
avec kurt cobain et dalida maintenant
mes coups
interroge sur réussir dans la vie ou
réussir sa vie il faut s'interroger sur
ce que l'on fait durant la vie qu'est ce
qu'on fait dans la vie voilà une bonne
question qu'est ce qu'on fait dans la
vie d'ailleurs généralement quand on
pose cette question à quelqu'un notre
interlocuteur va répondre sa profession
qu'est ce que tu fais dans la vie je
suis ingénieur avocats médecins
électricien horloger plombier boulangers
bouchers
c'est significatif de la place pas le
travail dans nos vies alors j'ai dû
réaliser un constat évident à titre
personnel il a fallu effectivement que
je me pose la question sur ce que je
voulais faire dans ma vie ce que je
voulais faire durant ma vie je savais au
moins une chose je voulais participer à
la construction de ce monde ce qui a pas
de paradoxal c'est que j'avais beau être
ingénieur en construction
rien ne rien ne m'a donné l'impression
de réellement participe à la
construction de ce monde en fait
initialement je voyais mon futur métier
comme une source de de plaisir de fierté
et d'estimé de soi
malheureusement j'ai subi une sorte de
désillusions en fait j'ai eu
l'impression qu'en tant qu'ingénieur
tout ce qu'on nous demande c'est de
trouver les solutions les plus rapides
rentable optimale efficace économique
mais dans quel but gagner notre vie
alors pendant longtemps je me suis dit
que c'était face au besoin de gagner ma
vie qu'il fallait que je travaille et je
suis content d'avoir compris
suffisamment tôt que j'avais tort et
même pire que j'étais en danger parce
que le travail est indispensable
oui pour répondre aux besoins humains
parce que travailler avant tout c'est
participent à la production des réponses
aux besoins des humains en fait le lien
de causalité par définition c'est on a
des besoins qui ne peuvent être produits
que par le travail
donc on travaille et donc par conséquent
on gagne ou on gagne notre vie et non
pas l' inverse à savoir
on a besoin de gagner d'argent donc on
travaille et donc on participe à la
création des réponses aux besoins des
humains enfin bien que beaucoup de
travaux ne participe pas réellement à la
pro
qui ont des besoins des humains mais ça
c'est un autre sujet alors j'ai dû
réaliser justement un constat à ce
moment là j'allais devoir prendre sur
moi une grosse partie de ma vie je lundi
au vendredi pour m'adonner à un travail
qui ne m'intéresse pas et encore une
fois j'étais pas le seul
beaucoup me disais mais c'est normal tu
es jeune patiente mais peut-être qu'un
jour tu finiras par trouver ton bonheur
dans ce métier alors ce qu'on me demande
c'est d'attendre que mon bonheur arrive
peut-être un jour avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard
c'est pas par hasard que l'idée travail
est souvent associée à l'idée de
souffrance et c'est pas par hasard
d'ailleurs que le mot travail lui-même
était employé en ancien français pour
désigner un tourment une souffrance
justement et que l'étymologie du mot
travail viendrait du latin pipe alliés
allaient qui signifie torturé avec ça le
tripalium alors ce n'est plus
d'actualité me direz vous et bien si
vous répondrais g et oui parce que j'ai
vu dans une étude de l'institut gallup
que 87% des personnes qui travaillent
dans le monde ne se sentent pas
impliqués par leur travail et même
d'après l'observatoire du stress au
travail
cinquante deux pour cent des
travailleurs présence présenterait un
niveau élevé d'anxiété et 24% de ce même
pas nous le travailleur présenterait un
état d'hyper stress c'est à dire un état
de stress tellement élevé qui peut avoir
un impact direct négatif sur notre santé
alors tout ça c'est le fruit de nombreux
facteurs concurrence avec les collègues
qui dégradent les relations sociales au
sein de l'entreprise ou même le travail
qui est mal prescrit par les managers
qui ont souvent tendance à confondre et
les notions de charge de travail et de
volume de travail
à cela peuvent s'ajouter le management
des objectifs
l'évaluation des résultats ou alors le
conflit de valeurs avec notre travail ou
la perte de sens de notre travail
alors tout ça c'est pas des arguments
que j'emploie à titre personnel c'est
les psychologues qui l'ont dit c'est des
psychologues qui on travaille sur ça
mais par contre ces choses là sont pour
tout ou partie des choses plusieurs
senti
quand je me levais le matin pour aller
au travail le travail devenait vite un
pensum ils nécessitaient besogneuse pour
gagner ma vie
on s'étonne même plus de l'absence de
regrets de nos collègues qui quittent
nos entreprises pour des offres plus
alléchantes
d'où d'ailleurs le fort turnover au sein
des entreprises qui est une tare qui est
une tare pour la perte des compétences
au sein de ces mêmes entreprises
mais je répondrai à ses collègues qu'ils
ont tort de penser qu'en cherchant une
meilleure rémunération
il arrive à guérir ce mal être au
travail
on a tendance à croire qu'en ce sens
quand que quand on se sent mal dans
l'entreprise dans laquelle on travaille
on va chercher une entreprise
concurrente chez qui on va avoir un
meilleur salaire pour guérir ce mal être
au travail chez qui on en aura marre de
travailler
donc on va chercher une entreprise chez
qui on leur un meilleur salaire chez qui
on en aura marre de travailler et encore
et encore et encore et encore en fait
c'est un peu comme si on cherchait la
tomate la plus rouge et la plus grosse
dans un champ de carottes
et le mal être au travail coûte de
l'efficacité et de la productivité aux
entreprises ça c'est des choses que j'ai
appris pendant ma formation qu'on se
mentent pas personne ne donne le
meilleur de soi même quand son bien-être
n'est pas assurée au travail et avec
l'avènement du numérique les tâches de
travail prennent une dimension de plus
en plus pénible en fait avec
l'automatisation des moyens de
production combinée à l'organisation
scientifique du travail non seulement de
nombreux métiers ont disparu mais en
plus la pénibilité a augmenté pour ceux
qui ont survécu
alors on a tendance à croire qu'en
faisant des études et en occupant des
postes de cadres de managers ont fui
cette pénibilité
malheureusement avec les intelligences
artificielles même des mêmes des
processus cognitifs comme la créativité
le raisonnement ou le calcul sont
remplacés par des machines
on pourrait se demander si les
ordinateurs ne serait pas en train de
remplacer les bureaux du futur en usine
du passé et puis les frontières
disparaissent avec internet
moi même je me suis retrouvé à me rendre
au bureau en pleine nuit pour faire des
affaires avec des entreprises situées à
gmt plus 10 ou plus 12 et on abuse des
moyens de communication digitaux combien
de fois un manager m'a envoyé un mail
alors que son bureau était situé à je
sais pas moi 6,7 mètres du mien pour me
demander de corriger telle ou telle
point sur un power point une sur un
excellent ou sur un plan mais bon vous
comprenez c'est pour économiser du temps
et le pire c'est que tu t'en on en
économise même pas vraiment au contraire
la gestion du temps de travail est un
fléau pour les entreprises encore une
autre anecdote le nombre de fois où je
me suis retrouvé à avoir une tâche de
travail à 17h30 à rome pour le lendemain
à la première heure aux clients alors
même que j'ai passé ma journée à mme
inventer des choses à faire ou le nombre
de fois où mon avance et dépendent et de
celle de mon manager ou d'un collègue à
moi qui prenais un ou deux jours à
arriver
encore une fois je n'étais pas le seul
j'ai vu dans une étude publiée par work
fronte que le travailleur moyen pas
seulement 39% de sa journée à réellement
travailler le reste est consacré à lire
des mails surfer sur les réseaux sociaux
se rendre à des meetings inutiles ou se
consacrer à des tâches administratives
par exemple
et le pire c'est qu'on passe un temps
conséquent nos vies au travail je me
suis amusé à calculer le temps en tout
cas la part de temps qu'un cadre donne
pour son activité de travail
d'après la cgt un cadre passent en
moyenne 44 virgule une heure par semaine
au travail ce qui correspond peu ou prou
à 8h50 de travail en moyenne
alors attention dans ce chiffre là ne
sont pas comptés cette heure de déjeuner
ou sept heures et demie de déjeuner ou
finalement à faire que de parler de
travail avec nos collègues
d'après des chiffres de l'insee
on passe en moyenne 1h30 par jour dans
les transports pour nous rendre au
travail
en plus de ça je me suis permis je me
suis permis d'ajouter un chiffre qui me
tenait à coeur qui vous savez sept
heures entre le moment où on quitte son
lit et le mans ou quitte son domicile
alors pour moi c'était une heure à peu
près de préparation c'est important
parce que à titre personnel j'avais
vraiment l'impression de travailler à
partir du moment où mon réveil sonner
tout ça combiné ça nous fait 11h20 de
temps de notre vie à l'échelle d'une
journée qui sont consacrés à notre
activité de travail
alors si on retire du reste vous savez
ces sept heures de sommeil qui sont
nécessaires mais insuffisantes
d'après l'institut national sommeil et
vigilance il ne nous reste plus que cinq
heures 40 minutes de temps libre ça
correspond à même pas 23 % de notre
temps à l'échelle d'une journée vous
savez c'est ce temps qu'on utilise pour
préparer à manger le soir ou pour
regarder le dernier épisode de game of
thrones où c'est pour voir cet ami avec
qui on s'était jurée d'aller boire un
verre mais qu'on n'a pas fait depuis des
mois parce que on manque de temps ou
même ce temps pour apprendre
instrument qu'on s'était juré
d'apprendre le jour on aura du temps ou
encore plus simplement que ça ce temps
qu'il nous reste pour prendre soin de
notre famille c'est tout bête dit comme
ça c'est une vérité toute simple mais on
attend on a tous les mêmes 24 heures
dans une journée
donc ce ratio temps hors du travail /
temps total un dénominateur qui changera
pour personne même pour tout l'or du
monde
pour informations à l'échelle d'une
semaine en ajoutant les week-ends ça
remonte pas à plus de 36 %
on nous dit que c'est pour le progrès
mais je suis pas certain que l'humain
progrès sur cet aspect là donc
maintenant il ne nous reste plus que
deux solutions soit on augmente ce
numérateur en passant plus de temps hors
du travail
sans oublier les chiffres que j'ai
citées précédemment 39 % de notre temps
est consacré à réellement travaillé et
52 % des travailleurs sont dans un état
élevé d'anxiété ou alors mieux que ça on
s'adonne à une tâche de travail qui nous
passionne et qui est bon pour nous et
pour la société et c'est ce que j'ai
décidé de faire meilleure je me rends
compte que je vous ai toujours pas dit
ce que je faisais dans la vie alors moi
dans la vie j'adore la musique j'adore
la danse
j'adore le théâtre j'adore le cinéma
quoi c'est ce que je fais dans la vie
nan mais s'il ya une chose que
aime par dessus tout moi dans la vie
c'est les gens moi j'aime comprendre les
gens leur parler les écouter leur poser
des questions pour connaître leur vie
leur expérience alors je sais ce que
vous vous dites
ouais c'est un illuminé mais moi au
moins j'ai conscience de ce qui me
passionne et j'ai conscience de ce que
j'aime et j'ai décidé d'en faire mon
métier
ah oui mon métier j'ai décidé d'être
prof je suis professeur enseignant alors
c'est vrai que c'est pas le métier qui
rend les personnes les plus heureuses
effectivement particulièrement en france
où la situation des profs mérite une
certaine réflexion et de toute urgence
selon moi au risque de subir une grave
crise de l'enseignement mais ça aussi
c'est un autre sujet mais au moins j'ai
résolu plusieurs problèmes
le premier c'est le sens de mon travail
le deuxième c'est le conflit de valeurs
avec mon travail parce que après tout
s'il ya bien une ressource durable dans
l'histoire de l'humain c'est bien le
savoir
et participez en donnant votre à la
multiplication du savoir à nos futurs
concitoyens somme toute enfin à nos
corps humain après tout il n'ya rien de
plus gratifiant de plus épanouissant ça
c'est vraiment pas du gâchis temps et
puis bon je passe peut-être pas beaucoup
moins de temps à travailler mais au
moins j'ai beaucoup plus de liberté pour
le gérer
ça fait d'ailleurs très longtemps que
j'ai pas entendu une personne me dire
tiens tu crois pas demi journée quand je
quitte à 17h30 et ce temps et tu t'en
bien employé bien usés j'ai jamais été
aussi stimulé sur un point de vue
cognitif cas l'idée de chercher des
solutions d exercice des méthodes des
discours pour transmettre les notions d'
analyse de calcul de raisonnement à nos
futurs concitoyens à nos corps humain et
c'est pour ça que j'ai décidé d'être
prof de maths parce que les
mathématiques permettent tout ça et
permettent d'expliquer beaucoup de
choses et en tant qu'ingénieur je crois
être bien placée pour le savoir
je ne prétends pas avoir trouvé la
solution au bonheur dans le travail mais
en tout cas mon expérience a été une
réussite et en aucun cas j'aimerais
donner au travail une image de simples
moyens de souffrir au contraire le
travail peut-être mêmes selon moi doit
être une source de plaisir de fierté et
d'estimé de soi
je pense qu'il faut qu'on s'emploie
beaucoup plus à réaliser ce que nous
aimons et à aimer ce que nous réalisons
parce que finalement l'amour de ce que
l'on fait nous incite à donner du temps
à le faire et le fait de donner du temps
à le faire c'est ça qui nous rend
excellent dans ce que l'on fait et après
tout
l'excellence c'est ça qui nous permet de
réussir nos vies merci beaucoup